all right good news tonight as pro-like
activist Mark Houck was acquitted by a
jury in Pennsylvania earlier today this
was after he was raided and arrested by
the FBI some 25 agents in September in
front of his family guns drawn and he
was charged with violating What's called
the face act now for this altercation
whether if you take a look with a
Planned Parenthood escort now as you can
see in your upper left hand corner Mark
accompanied by his son standing away
from the entrance to the clinic when he
is approached by the escort identified
as Bruce love who repeatedly try to
antagonize Houck allegedly verbally
harassing him and his son before Houck
eventually shoves him after multiple
attempts to Defuse The Situation the
Planned Parenthood manual clearly states
that escorts are not to antagonize or
even engage with any protesters a rule
let love clearly broke but this begs
another question why is Biden's doj so
so fixated on taking down pro-life
activists but seemingly uninterested in
the hundreds of attacks on pro-life
centers around the country or what's
happening outside of Supreme Court
Justices homes for example Mark joins us
now along with his attorney Peter uh
Breen Whitmore is with us uh thank you
both for being with us Mark let's talk
about this situation so first the arrest
part and you got arrested they had 25
agents 15 cars I read uh guns drawn is
that true
yeah that's true on September 23rd about
6 45 in the morning uh that that's uh
when those 20s so so called agents full
SWAT gear uh heavily armored vest
ballistic Shields helmets uh battering
ram uh banged on my door
and your kids were inside your wife was
inside okay let's run the video here and
why don't you explain to people where
you are in proximity to the Planned
Parenthood facility and this guy keeps
coming up to you and and tell us what
what happens from your perspective
there's the guy in the yellow and you're
the guy that he's approaching so what
happened
sure so at this point he's uh he's about
a foot away from my son uh after already
having one altercation with him uh and
now he's making my son extremely nervous
uh friends coming over that's out there
praying redirecting him uh my son moves
behind me I can tell he's visibly scared
uh there proceeds to be further insults
at me directed at my son about me and um
and at this point I I step in and I tell
Mr love you'll see right now to to go
back to where he normally stands so I
walk him there and uh tell him to stop
talking to my son he doesn't have any
permission to talk to my son next thing
I know he's turns around and he's
talking to my son again and then you see
the push
okay so it's not the worst thing in the
world but didn't you face up to 11 years
in jail for this
that's correct yes I did all right let's
let me bring in and I want to keep
running this because
I you know I don't know maybe I'm just a
little old-fashioned uh Peter Breen uh
and you're the attorney that won this
case but
um if a guy comes up to you repeatedly
on the street and is a threat to you and
your family and you're not even in front
of the facility isn't he down the block
from the facility
he was well away from the entrance and
the face act the federal act that they
charged here is about access to the
clinics it's not about dealing with
issues down the sidewalk and this issue
should have been in the municipal court
and actually was and the Municipal Court
threw it out because Mr love wouldn't
show up for trial so right here today
what we did was win a big victory for
the pro-life movement against the Biden
Administration they were trying to scare
pro-lifers from coming out on the
sidewalks and being active Biden that
doj sent their best prosecutor the top
guy for face prosecutions from
Washington to help deal with this case
in Philly and that jury once we finally
got it seated fully it took about an
hour to find Mark not guilty on all
charges I said I grew up watching the
Broad Street Bullies and Dave Schultz
and Hound Dog Kelly and Bobby Clark and
Rick mcleish and all these guys and
Bernie parent I'm sorry that push did
not warrant 11 years in jail however the
it was the Planned Parenthood guy that
kept going up to him and I don't know
did he ever threaten you Mark at all
yeah we've had many encounters over the
years uh it's been about 20 years that
I've been out there it's the first time
he's really overstepped his bounds uh
with and my son really was the the bait
for him and uh you know he says all he
he throws all sorts of insults vulgarity
at me and my son and uh you know I
usually just let it flow off my back
like a duck
all right well I'm glad you won this
case good job and Peter thank you you're
going to continue I assume your activism
now now the question is will the Biden
doj go after those groups that are
attacking pro-life organizations hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else